[Music]  to be a Getty is an extraordinary thing  my grandfather wasn't just the richest  man in the world  he was the richest man in the history of  the world we look like you but we're not  like  it's like we're from another planet  where the force of gravity is so strong  it bends the light  offends people too  mr. Getty go Cranston  17 million dollars to relieve him I  don't have any money get it from your  father-in-law you have all the money in  the world  mr. Gettys unavailable from sorry miss  getting I work for mr. Getty  I'll help you find yourself I'm not a  real yeah I just married one I'm  fighting an empire can you depend the  ransom they do things to Paul that  cannot be undone for any amount of money  I asked as a mother said my boy freakin  we have to show we're willing to walk  away I can't walk away  mr. Geller how much would you pay to  release your grandson if not 17 million  dollars nothing  [Applause]  [Music]  you  [Music]